hey everybody it's richard armor diag
and we're going to use full scan today
to see if we can uh
make a new key for a full transit
connect
okay first of all we're just going to
quickly um id our new key
make sure we've got the right chip in it
so we got a 4d63 chip and put the
original in here as well
make sure we've got the right one
and the same
so we're going to do is let's get the
ignition on let's get the program
started we'll swap over to the screen
and we'll see what we can do right okay
so we're uh
we're all logged into this so we'll just
have a look see what dtc's we got we've
got none in any of the modules so we're
happy with that
let's go down and we'll see if we can do
any patch programming
so we'll click into it come down and
press play
is the vehicle equipped with a keyless
push start no it's not
right so we just got a bit of a warning
here
saying about ignition key programming
difficulties extremes experienced a few
uh
a few bits and pieces here just giving
us a few warnings
so we're gonna just carry on go yeah
okay so we want to do ignition key
programming so there's already two keys
stored
and it says that at the top here as well
so we can erase
module initialization if you put a new
uh
instrument cluster in it we can clear
the keys out which we don't want to do
so we're going to ignition key
programming click ok
ok so set the ignitions to
position 0 and insert the new key
so i'll just turn it off there
grab the new key and we'll put it in
so what i'm going to do it's got the new
key
in with the ignition on and we're going
to press ok
all right so it's going to do the uh
access to the database with in codes
and it's going to sort out the out code
for us as well
would you like to do it now yes
i don't know how long this is going to
take as i say at the top here
it is saying it's generating the codes
or two percent down there
we'll just wait and see what it does
it says diag on the dash
okay so it's all finished it says about
um
the key has not increased yet but we've
got to turn the ignition on and off and
then recheck the uh
the monitor see if we've got three so
come off
back on press okay
no we got two
okay so i tried the uh key procedure a
couple of times and it doesn't seem to
be um giving me a higher key count
um it says everything's successful but
uh
probably what my thoughts are are
there's probably more likely an issue
with the key that i've got
rather than the program itself so
what i'm gonna do in the interest of
keeping the video a bit shorter so i
don't wanna
i'm trying not to make them over 10
minutes um what i'm going to do is i'm
going to order up a few different
transponders and i'm going to go through
and try a few different more
and see if we can get it working just to
make it a fair test
as i say i don't think it's the program
that's a problem i think it's more than
likely the key
so i'm going to do a few tests on that
um
and maybe convert it over to an 80-bit
chip from the 40-bit chip as well just
in case that's a problem but i don't
think it is on these earlier models
and we'll go from there so all right
come along for the next video
it'll be a part two to this and we'll
see if we can get it working
cheers